welcome back to the show let's go back
and hear from a few more people via
discord you can join the discord at
davidpakman.com
slash discord let's go to pablo from
albuquerque new mexico welcome pablo
pablo from albuquerque welcome please
unmute configure your microphone you're
on sorry there we go there you go you
can hear me now icon all right great um
so
um
the last time uh that i called then uh
you mentioned that you hadn't been to
new mexico before um
and it's unfortunate because right now
we actually have some really exciting
stuff um you know i don't know if you
heard
uh if we're making higher education free
for people that enrolled in six um
uh
six credit courses
and then
um you know we just legalized um
marijuana uh cannabis um
and my question is sort of uh
tied in with that uh
healthcare uh obviously that's one thing
that we tried and haven't been able to
uh make much progress with
um
do you think that a better way of
trying to
get a universal health care plan would
be also to go the exact same way
along with like cannabis legalization
meaning
just having a democrat or uh state
saying
if you're from here you'll get free
health or you'll get universal health
care
and then if you are from one of these
other states that also
um uh
supports universal health care
uh you'll have uh insurance uh covered
uh
through these uh states
so the details are a bit murky the way
you lay them out but here's how i could
see something like this working
states start to set up their own
single-payer plans okay vermont tried to
do it and it failed but it was a good
idea some state does it okay great
then a second state does it those states
could have an agreement
for um
sort of a consortium of sorts where now
there is a two-state single-payer system
the only part of this that i've not yet
figured out is what happens if tons of
people who work in other states
move to those states just for the health
care you've got to make sure that you're
capturing their taxes and there are ways
where listen if you have if you work
from home
for a big corporation and you move from
texas to arizona for arizona
single-payer in theory you now live in
arizona you should pay taxes in arizona
but for a lot of smaller businesses and
and entrepreneurs you can live in one
place but kind of maintain residency in
another and not pay taxes where you're
living so that would have to be figured
out but i love the idea of starting
single-payer or something like it at the
state level and as states do it they can
work as a consortium to expand the risk
pool i think it's a beautiful idea
um yeah and um the reason that i brought
up the um
uh university a higher university that's
the way that they're also uh they're
saying if you've um resided in new
mexico for at least 12 months then uh
you're allowed to um get the um
you know free or subsidized uh health
care right um and so but yeah as you
said for smaller um
places it'd be a lot uh harder to do i
suppose
um
yeah but um
i think that's about it oh
there was one other thing i can't
remember all right well let's save it
for next time pablo from albuquerque
thank you for the call very
important issue